all right jada
hi jada uh where you from originally i
am from fairfield california
so up north
that's by sacramento yeah sacramento san
francisco
hour away tell me about your uh your
family
um my family i come from i had a great
childhood so i come from a really good
home
i was raised by my mom and my stepdad
who came into my life at the age of one
so he raised me my whole life
um i have i'm the oldest out of five or
out of four i got three sisters one
brother
um
i haven't i didn't really have no
traumatic
like
childhood like a lot of girls have so
many childhood how'd you end up working
the streets uh i got caught up with
a dude that introduced me to this
and
i fell in love with the money so i just
never stopped
even after stopping even after i stopped
messing with him like
he
came on to you as a boyfriend
uh no he he told me he was a pimp
just like from straight up because he
had other girls
before i started messing with him but i
was working
a regular job
so when he lost his girl that he had
he
started messing around with me but he
didn't really push it on to me or forced
it onto me it's just
our situation and i wanted to better it
and he said well you know what i do and
i'm like let's do it well it wasn't
really forced on me it was by choice
yeah how old are you i'm 21. i just
turned 21 in january it seems it seems
like a lot of the girls young girls i'll
interview
see this is almost like a glamorous
lifestyle
[Music]
i don't think it's glamorous honestly
like
i'm doing this to get out a lot of girls
do this and get stuck in it
so i don't think it's glamorous it's not
fun it's very dangerous
and it's a hard lifestyle
it's very very hard yeah the money might
look good and all the cars and the
jewelry and all that stuff but
it's deeper than that it's a lot of
stuff we go through you've been in l.a
how long you said what you've been in
los angeles how long uh i just got back
to la last week so i'll be going back
and forth because all my family live up
there so
i go visit them so you'll work up up
north as well as here
i don't i like to say i don't want to
[ __ ] where i stay
so i don't like to work up there i only
like to work down here and stuff oh i
see
so you have somebody currently
helping you no not right now you're on
your own yep
so it's just me right now
and
i don't really um you know have a lot of
bad experiences with the tricks that i
get
i normally get pretty cool when so like
i've only really really been in one bad
situation
which was when i got robbed basically he
pulled the gun out on me
forced me to have sex with him took the
money back and that's it that's the only
time that i've ever been in a bad
experience and i've been doing this for
two years now and that that kind of
stuff happens to a girl like yourself
yeah but it happens a lot like girls
that happened a lot to girls yeah it
only happened once to me so i like
i feel like i'm lucky like i'm blessed
but you can't call the cops in that
situation exactly because you're
you're doing something illegal too
yeah
so it's like you really don't have
nobody you have no kids right no no kids
no
i'm too young
do you recall your very first time
well doing this doing this yeah uh yeah
i remember like it's yesterday honestly
i had on my work uniform
from the security job i was working
it was a black sweater and like some
khaki shorts with some black tennis
shoes
and it was out in oakland my first time
i caught a lot of dates though
surprisingly dressed like that
but
it was
i wasn't scared and i think honestly i
felt like it was
not even a thrill it was like a whatever
honestly i feel like
like after you do it the first time does
it become like all right that wasn't so
bad i can do this
i would think that becomes the biggest
hurdle is yeah
and i feel like that's where a lot of
girls get stuck
like
they will
how can i say this
they'll be so infatuated with this
lifestyle and the money and stuff that
they forget like you're doing this to
elevate and get out of this you
shouldn't want to do this forever i know
if i don't want to do this forever like
i'm 21 right now i want to be done
before i'm 25.
like
um
i went to school and stuff you know
graduated high school did a year of
college
but college didn't really work out for
me like that because my living situation
so right now i'm just focusing on
stacking my money you're saving money
stacking my money and finding me a place
i can get stable
and get back to school because i was
going to school for medical assistant i
always wanted to be in the medical field
i like helping people so
i just gotta get my stuff right yeah at
25 you'll still be young to do that
because there's girls out there that's
in their 30s and their 40s and
i was like oh my god how could you do
this for that long like they get stuck
mm-hmm so i try to look at them kind of
for motivation like you don't want to be
like that so don't get stuck in this
life like yeah the money's good
and it's fast but
this lifestyle is dangerous and
it's like
sucks all the energy out of you like
it's draining like this morning i didn't
even want to get up because i was out
all night last night until like five in
the morning
and i like dragged myself up because i
know i gotta go get some money i didn't
make no money last night i gotta get
some money you started you started
working what time last night uh last
night i started at like 11 30 until five
in the morning
and then i went in
and then
i woke up at like a check out pay for my
room
and then went outside again
are drugs a part of your life
i smoke weed that's it no hardcore drugs
for me i like to be sober when i'm
outside
be aware of my surroundings you know
there's a lot of crazy people out there
who can't be high or drunk
doing this type of work i feel like
so i like to stay sober and then when
i'm done
working you know in my room relaxing
i'll smoke
some weed or whatever what's your what's
your typical kind of john
um like what do you mean a lot of
mexicans figure out um yeah i get a lot
of mexicans and
a lot of white men a lot of black dudes
pull over for me too but i stopped
dating black dudes a while ago because
just too many bad experiences with them
so like if you're probably a older
african-american man i might date you
just depending on how i feel got to fill
out the vibe first if i don't get a good
vibe from you i won't date you
like
i
i got good characteristic skills like i
can fill somebody out
well so that's why i feel like i don't
be in a lot of bad situations
does this work get to you emotionally
the only part that really gets to me is
not being around my family being gone
because i'm like so used to being around
them so i feel homesick sometimes that's
why i do travel back and forth back and
forth like i'm leaving on friday
actually to go back up there for to
spend mother's day with my mom since i
missed it
but besides that i don't really it
really don't affect me emotionally just
the family part means being so far away
from them for so um so long because when
i leave i'd be gone for months so
does your family know you're doing it
well
they do know
well my dad knows for sure he know cause
he he's blunt so last time i was over
there he told me like
i seen your ad in anaheim like i know
you're still doing that i'm not gonna
tell your mom because my mom it really
hurts my mom that does this like she
don't understand cause i come from a
really good family like a really really
good home so she don't understand why i
do this
but my dad he knows i'm still doing it
he's not dumb he's not gullible he's up
to date with everything so he's like he
be confronting me he's like
i know you're still doing it like i've
seen your ad out there in orange county
and stuff i'm not gonna tell your mom
though so my mom don't think i'm doing
it but my dad he still you know someone
knows
he has
a little feeling i guess it's gonna be
heartbreaking for a parent
yeah it is
it is especially when they like
they don't really they really don't
understand and i like i can't really
explain it to them why i still do this
why do you why do you think you're doing
it
i understand the money but but there's
probably more to it than that it's
easier than working a job honestly like
how much do you make a night typically
um
and last night last night was a rough
night but but typically because i don't
normally i don't work at night i work in
the daytime like right now so
on a good day
i can make at least a thousand
to twelve hundred a slow probably like
for
anywhere between 400 and 700 it just
depends on how the day goes like i said
i don't like to work figaro at night it
gets too crazy with the pimps and the
police and
the gangbangers and all that stuff so i
try to avoid to go at night
as much as possible
but yesterday i didn't go out in the
daytime i slept all day
so i went out at night
you realize it's a crazy thing you're
doing
right
yeah it hasn't become normalized in your
in your head
where it's just it's just what you do
it's do you still see it as something
crazy
not really not anymore yes you know
you've normalized yeah it's normalized
now
it's like a everyday thing so i'm used
to it
i just know that
i don't want to get stuck in it
so
girls getting robbed girls getting raped
kidnapped killed killed
it's dangerous that's why it's like
i don't understand how a girl can get
raped or kidnapped or hurt and then go
right back outside
most jobs a person would quit yeah like
my cousin she's also she also do this
type of work she's been doing it for
longer than me
and she told me a story one time she
don't she won't ever come back to l.a
ever because something really bad
happened to her out here but it's like
girl how can you
how can that happen to you you know you
basically had to run for your life you
was trapped and a heck of a little stuff
but you still do this type of work like
if you're that traumatized
i wouldn't even come come back to la or
do this type of work at all
but i guess people have different
mindsets she just feel like she's safer
out there up north than she is down here
but it's like that same thing can happen
to you up there
you know it can happen anywhere
most of the girls i've interviewed come
from broken homes their dads weren't
around i don't know you have a good
family
yeah that's why like a lot of girls
outside they be looking at me like when
i tell them my story too they be like so
why are you doing this i'm like i got
stuck in it basically like i don't want
to stop now i'm addicted to the money
are you addicted to the fast money
i never like no job that i worked i
never made as much money as i do
doing this so
i didn't want to stop
your parents were a good example of a
loving relationship
yeah
they um they were together
15 my dad the one that my stepdad he
went away for like a year or so i think
he went to jail or something
or prison or something for a minute so
my mom ended up getting pregnant with me
and then my dad got out and then they
just stayed together ever since
so
i love their relationship though it's
cute
this is a lonely lifestyle for you
lonely
sometimes
i get lonely but
not really honestly
like
i am i like to call myself a popular
loner so everybody know me but i always
be by myself i like to stay to myself
it's just i've been in a lot of [ __ ]
up situations trying to help somebody
out and they stab me in the back
so i just tend to stay to myself now
when doing this type of work i don't
like bringing people around me have you
been in love before
yeah of course
who has it well i don't call it love i
call it lust high school stuff that's
lust
how is this how does this work affect
your self-worth i mean you have all
these guys that are
attracted you know offering you money
for your attention
and that's got to be flattering but it
also kind of can undermine it no
not really because it's like
when i started doing this like
it kind of building my self-esteem kinda
sorta in a way which is weird to say but
it's like
you get all these men who are willing to
pay just to some men are willing to pay
you just to talk to you
so it's like
these men is willing to pay you just for
you to be in their face because because
they're attracted to you because they
think you're so beautiful so it's like
you're being praised sometimes
there are some guys that just come out
there and just want to [ __ ] and then you
never see them again but
like me i'd be looking for regulars and
my regulars
like we build a connection a bond
like friendship type of thing i feel
like that's better just because they'll
last longer
so and they'll pay me more
and they're safer
yeah and i don't have to go outside and
things like that i can just call them
so
and then
of course i don't want to be on outside
with this one of course so i try to do
any and everything i can to avoid
walking on fig i hate fig now
it's just so
i don't know chaotic
it is
and i don't like i like to avoid drama
and things like that so
me being my figure like gives me anxiety
sometimes because like oh my god this
[ __ ] is crazy
i'd rather sit in the room and make my
money that way
it's easier safer
don't gotta deal with too much do you
believe in karma definitely
definitely how does karma affect you
i feel like i have good karma because i
am
i'm a good person you know
i don't rip people off i don't rob
people i don't steal i don't lie i'm a
very honest person kind loving laid
chill back
so i feel like i always have good karma
even when somebody does [ __ ] up
something [ __ ] up to me i still end up
like
benefiting from it because all right let
me tell you a story so like it was this
girl that i was trying to help out i
knew her from the bay area
and like she went to jail and things
like that she didn't have no money so
you know i'm like i know you you can
come stay with me i fed her
you know let her stay at my room for a
couple days
and then
one night
she robbed me for you know 30 30 200 i
think i had in my wallet or in my purse
so she took all my money but like
she did that and then that same day that
same morning i went outside and i found
a good trick
that gave me what how much he gave me i
think he gave me like 1200 or something
so it was like i lost 32 but i just made
12. there's your karma yeah
so and i know she's home
she's going to give something to her i
don't have to do nothing to her
something's going to happen to her
so
do you see yourself more as a therapist
for lonely men or do you you know you
could also see it as
you're
you're facilitating in these men
cheating on their wives
that's a hard question
because like just two sides of the same
coin yeah
okay so
like
i feel like some men do be lonely
so i do be like
therapeutic but like
for the men that are married they be
having their own reasons why they do
what they do like i have a regular out
in san francisco and he just wants me
you know to give him head because
his girlfriend has a really bad gag
reflex so he she don't never give him
head
so he's like that's the only reason why
i do this because he like she don't give
me head she can't she has a really bad
gag reflex
so everybody has a story of why they do
what they do
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that do this kind
of work
um
i feel like
a lot of people
judge prostitutes or hoes whatever you
want to call them
because they just see what we're doing
they see that we're
we're degrading ourselves you know
selling our body so they think that
we're giving our money away to pimps and
some girls is but everybody's not like
that and i feel like you really that's
why like i said i like you because
you're giving us a chance to explain our
story and give people an understanding
of what we go through why we do what we
do
it's not just because we like to have
sex or because we want some money is
because we've been through [ __ ] like
traumatic [ __ ] like girls been raped and
when they were seven years old and
that's why they started doing this and
it's just all type of crazy things that
happens
do you think you
you deserve a better life lifestyle than
this
definitely you do definitely that's why
i said i don't want to do this forever
because i have so much potential and
knowledge
that i know that i can be doing better
it's just right now i'm all
[ __ ] off i'm all distracted with this
yeah but once i get i feel like once i
get back on track
i ain't gonna you ain't never gonna see
me on figaro again it's a hard lifestyle
because everybody's a hustler yeah
everyone's counting somebody whether
it's the tricks the pimps the
yeah even the cops the other girls
everybody's up to no good right
it's sometimes it's like that yeah
you just got to be cautious
you got to be very alert i feel like
when you're doing this type of work like
you can't be slipping basically
do you regret the path that your life is
taking
you're only 21 so you have a lot of time
to straighten things out but do you
sometimes because like i think about
like
them what if i would have just stayed in
college and finished doing my medical
assistant and
things like that and what if i never
even said anything to that guy at that
hotel like just ignore him
like it'll be so many things and so many
scenarios going through my head but it's
like
i feel like god did this for a reason
like i don't know why yet but
everything's happened for a reason so
i feel like he's trying to show me
something or teach me something i just
don't know what yeah
but what advice would you give to a girl
about your age who
will probably come across some of the
same opportunities that
you
could have passed on but you took
and you know when these opportunities
come to them what would you tell them to
do
i would tell them
to
stay focused like if you got gotta
if you're on the right path
and somebody's trying to steer you off
or
you get steered off you gotta stay
strong you gotta keep going because i
honestly wish sometimes that i did just
keep staying just staying in school
or just
never even said anything to that guy
like i said like
what if i didn't say anything to him
when i walked down the stairs what if i
would have kept walking
you know i wouldn't probably be doing
this have you changed in the two years
you've been doing this um i feel like i
have i'm a little bit more aggressive
now like sometimes with my tricks like
the ones that i don't know just because
if they i feel like if they see you're
weak and vulnerable and too nice they'll
try to take advantage of you so so you
pick up a trick and you guys agree to
what like 100 bucks something like that
do you try to hustle them out of more
money of course
tell me how you do that okay so
no they give me a hundred bucks i'll
tell them i'll probably lie to them 30
minutes give them 10 minutes
suck their dick they're gonna they're
gonna wanna [ __ ] so you wanna have sex i
need another hundred dollars
you wanna touch my boob
i need another
fifty dollars so once you once you get
them one-on-one then you start
yeah
the the hustle starts right
some tricks are easier than famous than
others some of them you got a little you
got to strategize a little more
but
it's the ones that the ones that be
knowing about
like cohen too like the girls be telling
tricks about hoeing and pimping and
stuff like i have this trick that i just
dated last night and he was telling me a
whole bunch of stuff and i'm like how do
you know all this stuff like hoes tell
me i'm like why do they tell you this
like like what kind of stuff
like um
basically like what i just told you like
how to finesse how they be finessing the
tricks and stuff like why would you tell
them that you're not supposed to tell
them that then they're going to catch on
and but oh no i already know the deal
like him i cannot like he'd be like no
he's just giving me a hundred dollars
some some of the some of the girls have
told me that they're definitely trying
to get the guy's watch or his wallet or
his whatever yeah they do that a lot of
other ones are just
you know it's just sex for money and
that's it there's no games yeah they do
that a lot in vegas
and i'm here too surprisingly but i feel
like
girl if you got a rob a trick then you
don't need to be doing this because you
putting your life in danger for one and
you gonna put other girl's life at
dangers too because
you might make him so mad that he decide
he want to go kill somebody go kill a
girl outside for no reason because of
what you did
i remember one time i got picked up by a
guy he had a gun sitting in his middle
part you know and i had asked him what
it was before whatever and he's like
he's looking for a girl she was looking
for a girl out there in her and her pimp
because i guess they just had robbed him
so i'm like see that's the type of stuff
i'd be talking about like
y'all be doing these things to these
people and y'all don't even know how
crazy they are
like he over here looking for you now
driving up and down fig looking for you
trying to find you with a gun
and i just try to avoid that
by giving people what they pay for like
i'm gonna keep it i'm gonna be 100 with
you the only thing i might lie about is
how much time you're gonna get
that's the only thing but i'm gonna tell
you like give me a hundred dollars that
you're not gonna get full service
and
anything if everything is extra
everything you get asked to do things
without a condom for example yeah that's
why that's another reason why i'm
starting to hate fig
because it's like a lot of girls out
here is doing bareback like for a
hundred dollars like
tricks be pulling up for me they offer
me like 60. i tell them like a hundred
they'd be like is that with beer i'm
like no like what do you mean like and
i'm like i'll do 80 full service with a
condom like i'm not doing my beer though
like
tell me about the uh the jewelry on your
on your ankle
oh
so
this is a crazy story
so i had got a date off a fig one time
and we went back to the dude was drunk i
can tell he was drunk this is like when
i first started prostituting too so i
can tell he was drunk we went to my room
he gave me the money but like his hands
was like they had cement or something on
them and i kept telling him like you
gotta wash your hands you gotta wash
your hands gotta wash your hands he kept
like he went in there he washed him but
it was still on his hands somebody just
don't touch me like i'm just gonna you
know give your head whatever
and then he started getting aggressive
you know he started trying to
stick his fingers in me touch me after i
just told him no like i'm just gonna
give you head like
so i had to call the dude i was messing
with at the time
and you know he came in there he tried
to get the dude out but the dude was so
drunk like he was like
i'm not going nowhere y'all better leave
y'all better leave you know and i'm like
how the [ __ ] you gonna tell us to leave
this is our room like
so they end up fighting and stuff and in
the middle of the fight somebody got
stabbed i don't know if it was the dude
my dude that i was messing with or if it
was the trick
but i just seen a whole bunch of blood
so i'm like
grabs his keys off the um the dresser
where he sat on that and i got his car
and i drove it like downtown somewhere
and i left it there called me uber to my
homegirl house and i stayed there i went
home
the next morning went back up north
i came back out here like a month or two
later
and i was on fig my regular picked me up
the police
they seen me get in the car so they
pulled us over now normally when i get
pulled over i use them i'll be using
like my cousin name
or i use my friend name but i was like
nervous so i told them my cousin name
but i gave them my address that was on
my id
so when they told the dispatcher the
address or whatever i guess they told
them like that's not my name
because they were already looking for me
because they had my id from the hotel
that i was staying at
so
they're like what's your real name blah
blah blah i gave them my real stuff
they detained me that's like you gotta
go talk to the um
uh what's it called d.a or whatever
about a robbery i'm like a robbery i
didn't rob nobody
i go there
uh
what they tried to question me i told
them i plead the fifth or i want a
lawyer attorney they booked me a bailed
out
when i bailed out though
my first day at court they told me to go
get this they told me they like go to
lancaster go get you the ankle monitor
put on i didn't go do it i went back up
north for like
six seven months
and i didn't put this back home i didn't
go get it i never went to go get it
because lancaster was too far i didn't
have no money i didn't have no car
so they and they never said anything
about me going to get it so i'm like
whatever i'm not going to say anything
so when i came down here for what was
that super bowl weekend
i came down here for super bowl weekend
and
i got caught on fig again
with undercover i tried to run and hide
in the bushes but they found me
they found me they looked at my name i
had a warrant because i had missed court
i didn't even know
went to court the judge instead of
making me stay in jail she just put this
on me so yeah that's the crazy story so
what does it mean you can't go
no i can't well at first i couldn't
leave la
so
my probation officer like she was like
i'm making her job harder because i keep
moving from hotel to hotel to hotel so
every time i moved to a hotel
she got to change the address so that my
theme could be relocated i could only be
outside from like
i think eight in the morning until like
six at night or seven at night so
every time i moved hotels she had to
switch the address and then eventually
she just like
requested that i was just on the
house arrest but without the
restrictions so
now i can move freely like i've been to
vegas with this on i've been back up
north i've been down here did you travel
to other cities other than la
um only vegas i've only been to vegas
and that's it so vegas
i was working in vegas compared to l.a i
don't like vegas because
i feel like you got to be aggressive and
i'm not an aggressive person like when
you work in the casinos and stuff you
have to approach the trick the trick
don't normally approach you
so i don't really like that they do have
a blade out there though too their blade
was okay like my first day i got out
there was four hundred dollars off the
blade
so the blade is okay but i don't like to
strip for the casinos
it's not me i'm not an aggressive person
i'm really shy and quiet so
it makes me like uncomfortable that i
have to get out of my comfort zone to
get some money because i'm so used to
being out here and stuff and them
approaching me
but
i guess that's just something i got to
get over because it's a lot of money in
vegas
a lot a lot of money in vegas like my
home girl she just came from vegas
and she was having two thousand dollars
three thousand dollar nights out there
so there's money out there definitely
you just gotta
know how to work it work the strip and
work the casinos
so
jada what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
21 years
the most important thing that i've
learned is
oh
i don't know what is the most important
thing that i've learned
i guess not to be so vulnerable
to keep my guard up because people will
backstab you betray you
and snake you at the end of the day
people don't care people are hard
like
cold-hearted they don't care about
nobody but themselves especially doing
this type of work in this game
nobody don't care about you
from the other girls outside from the
pimps from even the tricks don't nobody
give a [ __ ] about you you out here on
your own doing this
like
so i learned how to stop being so
vulnerable like i've seen girls that i
know
out here you know like i said they
backstab me so i got to stop
being so comfortable so vulnerable so
nice
to people
[ __ ]
so that's what i learned i learned don't
be too nice
doing this [ __ ] you got to be
aggressive you got to be a little mean
sometimes because people will try to
take your kindness for weakness
and i don't like that
all right jada thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you this is a
pleasure
thank you very much
you